- Plus tôt cette semaine,
nous avons suivi le quotidien
de Julie Arbour, une mère
monoparentale qudodoit gérer
un casse-tête financier.
Ses attentes envers
le gouvernement pour l'aider
à joindre les deux bouts étaient
grandes.
Qu'est-ce que vous aimeriez
entendre de ce budget-là?
- Un miracle.
(rires)
ususus sommes retournés la voir
aujourd'hui pour l'informer
du crédit d'impôt remboursable
de 500 $ qu'elle pourra toucher.
JULIE ARBOUR
- Hé! 500 $ unique? Euh...
J'ai pas de mots!
- Ça couvre à peine ses dépenses
en essence comme représentante
d'un courtier en alimentation.
Qu'est-ce qui vous déçoit
le plus?
- Qu'il n't t t pas de barème
au niveau du pourcentage
d'augmentation. Par exemple,
au niveau des logements, c'est
libre au choix du propriétaire.
L'augmentation au niveau
de l'électricité n'a pas
un plafond d'arrêt.
- La famille Fauteux nous avait
aussi ouvert les portes de leur
5 et demi dans les Laurentides.
Avec un revenu familia
de 92 000 $, ils obtiendront
1000 $ du gouvernement.
JOANIE SIMARD
- Bien! comme c'est un 1000 $
qui arrive d'un coup,
probablement que je vais juste
le mettre de côté et ça va
aur r r r encore plus ma mise
de fond ou si je veux faire
des rénovations dans la maison
qu'on veut, mais j'espère
un jour y avoir accès!- - - - Lr
une maison s'éloigne encore,
puisque le budget ne contient
aucune mesure pour les aider
à accéder à la propriété.
VÉRONIQUE LAFLAMME,
porte-parole du FRAPRU
- On a la confirmation que
le gouvernement, soit ne prendps
du logement vécues au Québec
par les ménages locataires
ou minimisent l'urgence
des besoins, mais dans les deux
cas, je vous dirais que c'est
catastrophique.
- Les groupes de pression
s'étonnent que si peu de leurs
suggestions aient été retenues.
RENAUD BROSSARD, Fédération
canadienne des contribuables
- Une meilleure fa
- Il y aurait eu d'autres
mesures qui auraient pu être
choisies. Par exemple, les taxes
sur l'essence présentement.
On a vu l'Alberta qui les a
retirées.
- Leanananananants
- Un beau 500 $, effectivement
qu'on ne refusera pas ça
avec l'inflation et le
de la vie, donc j'avoue
que soudainement, je suis
très contente.
- J'ai l'impression de me faire
acheter, carrée e e e e e que
500 $, c'est quoi, aujourd'hui?
Tout est rendu cher,
à l'épicerie, là.
- Avec 500 $ seulement pour elle
et sa fille, Julie Arbour espère
encore de l'aide pour couvrir
l'augmentatisssssss
d'hydroélectricité, un gros
point d'interrogation dans son
budget et celui du g
Ici Véronique Prince,
Radio-Canada, Québe